[Música]
quisiera proponerles que por pequeños
instantes traten de ponerse en el lugar
de una persona que por primera vez
visita a bariloche les pregunto cual
piensan ustedes que es la postal que esa
persona que por primera vez nos visita
se va a llevar como el gran recuerdo de
nuestra ciudad
probablemente vamos a estar todos de
acuerdo creo en que esa postal sí o sí
va a tener las montañas los bosques y
también va a tener esos grandes lagos y
ríos de aguas transparentes
pero para los que vivimos aquí en
bariloche que pasamos los 365 días del
año
esa postal es la misma
hay otras postales posibles para cada
uno de nosotros
de qué manera cada uno de ustedes cada
uno de nosotros nos involucramos en esa
portal participamos de esa postal
hablar de medio ambiente no solo es
pensar en el paisaje en lo de
prácticamente lo que describe una postal
en nuestra ciudad sino también es hablar
de la idea que a mí me interesa mucho
poder transmitirles qué es la idea de
percepción y qué es esto no es ni más ni
menos que la forma en que cada uno de
nosotros
visualizamos y percibimos y apreciamos
el ambiente en el que vivimos
bariloche tiene un montón de problemas
ambientales probablemente ustedes ya los
conozcan pero yo me voy a referir a creo
desde mi punto de vista a los que son
los dos más importantes problemas
ambientales que actualmente tenemos en
nuestra ciudad el primero es la
contaminación del lago lago nahuel huapi
el segundo es el de la basura
en el primero en el de la contaminación
del lago
decimos estar preocupados por la
contaminación pero resulta que casi un
40% de la población de la ciudad aún no
tiene o no está conectada a una red
cloacal
existen por otro lado descargas
clandestinas que en realidad ya dejan de
ser clandestinas porque creo que cada
uno de nosotros si recorremos la costa
del lago podemos percibir
y también tenemos una planta que se
encuentra superada en su capacidad de
tratamiento porque porque nos quedó
chica somos muchos y la planta no
alcanza
por el otro lado
también decimos de estar preocupados con
la basura saben cuánta basura producimos
por día en nuestra ciudad 170 toneladas
de 2000 imaginen 25 camiones uno detrás
del otro camiones recolectores entrando
todos los días al vertedero a tirar esa
basura vertedero del cual también
decimos que estamos preocupados por la
ubicación en la que está que está
generando cada vez más problemas
pero
por ejemplo no nos concientizamos en la
necesidad de tener que reciclar o
comenzar a reciclar nuestra basura o
generar menos basura y resulta que los
grandes recicladores de nuestra basura
no son las empresas que con su
tecnología se dedican a hacer eso sino
son los sectores más pobres y
vulnerables que a diario viven de la
venta de nuestros residuos
en este punto me gustaría preguntarme y
preguntarles a todos
percibimos de la misma manera el
problema de la contaminación del lago
que el problema de la basura
son el mismo problema
perciben de la misma manera el problema
de la basura una persona que vive en la
parte alta de nuestra ciudad y que a
diario convive con el vertedero que una
persona que vive en el centro de la
ciudad
pensar en el medio ambiente también es
pensar en otra idea que me gustaría
transmitirles
y que es la de los factores sociales y
qué es esto de los factores sociales son
aquellas personas organizaciones e
instituciones que no sólo participan de
la gestión
sino también de la transformación de una
sociedad cuando escucho hablar de medio
ambiente siempre me pregunto
a veces me pregunto
tenemos que conservar el ambiente pero
para quien tenemos que conservarlo de
quien debemos conservarlo
qué les parece el ambiente se debe
conservar o se debe usar
en mi opinión y por la experiencia
de los años que llevo trabajando con el
ambiente
creo que deberíamos apropiarnos pero en
el buen sentido de la palabra
apropiarnos de los recursos naturales y
hacer un uso racional de él pero también
responsabilizarnos por los que cada una
de nuestras acciones generen sobre el
ambiente
si yo les preguntara a cada uno de
ustedes qué puede hacer por conservar el
ambiente en donde viven
no me van a poder contestar ahora pero
probablemente
algunos días muchos otros digan poco y
espero que nadie diga nada
esta misma pregunta que les hago ahora
se hizo en una encuesta ambiental ya
hace un tiempo atrás en todo nuestro
país y el 50% de los encuestados
respondió que podía ser poco o nada por
conservar el ambiente acá aparece una
paradoja por un lado tenemos un discurso
en el que decimos que debemos cuidar el
ambiente que lo debemos conservar lo
debemos proteger pero por otro lado
estamos diciendo que podemos hacer poco
o nada por conservarlo
hace un tiempo
no mucho
y tuve la posibilidad de leer un libro
cuyo título era porque el riachuelo
problema ambiental en argentina si los
hay porque el riachuelo sigue
contaminado y en este libro se
analizaban las diferencias
y similitudes del saneamiento del
riachuelo y se lo comparaba con el
saneamiento del río támesis en la
capital británica el autor de este libro
sostiene algo que para mí era
interesante o es interesante
y él dice que los actores sociales
involucrados en el caso del saneamiento
del río támesis eran muy diferentes a
los actores sociales involucrados en el
riachuelo
el río támesis
atraviesa una gran parte
del lo citó textual al autor porque me
gusta la frase
atraviesa una parte del área más
histórico monumental más emblemática de
riqueza y poder de gran bretaña por lo
tanto los actores sociales en ese monte
en ese ruido
van a tener una mayor presión política y
social que los las víctimas de la
contaminación del riachuelo que se
encuentra ubicado dice el autor en el
patio trasero de buenos aires a partir
de esta idea se me ocurre hacer la
siguiente analogía nuestro lago nahuel
huapi que lo podemos ubicar en el frente
de nuestra casa
y que representa una de las postales
turísticas más importantes de nuestra
ciudad
la resolución del problema ambiental más
tarde que temprano parece ir
solucionándose
veamos lo que en el marzo de 2016
titulaba el diario 'el país' diario
internacional el paraíso que visito
obama en la patagonia en riesgo de
contaminación título fuerte el paraíso
y también acompañado por una foto que a
mi entender representa mucho del emblema
de riqueza y poder que habla el autor
del libro un año y medio después veamos
lo que titulaba un diario regional
bariloche comenzó la ampliación de la
planta depuradora
sin embargo el problema ambiental que
está generando el basurero en nuestra
ciudad parece cada vez más lejano
y este basurero que lo ubicamos
en la parte trasera de nuestra casa cada
vez genera más problemas veamos lo que
titulaba un diario regional en enero del
2016 la basura el eterno problema en
bariloche ya no es el paraíso sino el
eterno problema
dos años y medio después o sea hace muy
poquito un blog de noticias locales
titulaba se duplicó la cantidad de
familias que comen del basurero en
nuestra ciudad siempre me pregunto qué
hubiese pasado si en el lugar de la
bolsa de basura estaban los dos
presidentes como se hubiese resuelto el
problema del basurero
pensar en el medio ambiente nos impone
un desafío que es ampliar esa postal que
hablaba al principio e incluirlos a
nosotros como protagonistas de esa
postal
resolución de nuestros problemas
ambientales en mi opinión
tiene que ir de la mano de lo económico
y lo social
debemos entender que problemas
ambientales generan problemas sociales
y los problemas sociales generan
problemas ambientales en otras palabras
la relación medioambiente sociedad es
tan importante tan esencial que una
desigual distribución de la riqueza
va a generar indefectiblemente un
aumento de la pobreza y ésta
de una u otra manera conlleva a un
deterioro ambiental finalmente y para
que sigamos pensando y reflexionando
sobre los problemas ambientales no solo
de nuestra ciudad sino de todos los
problemas ambientales porque estos
problemas no son exclusivos del
bariloche
me gustaría que reflexionemos cada uno
en su casa con sus amigos sus familias
en las escuelas sobre estas dos
preguntas de qué manera cada uno de
nosotros nos vinculamos con el entorno
en el que vivimos
y de qué manera las acciones que
nosotros generamos sobre ese entorno van
a afectar a nuestra sociedad y a nuestra
cultura muchas gracias
[Aplausos]